I felt Invincible but I also felt like I
discovered a cheat sheet this was no
funding nothing at all I used my like
skills and my brains to like figure out
how things work what you're about to
hear is an interview between me and
Timothy armu who goes by Timo Timo
started his first company at the age of
14. he sold his second company at the
age of 17 and he started a company
called fan bites which recently sold for
somewhere between 20 and 50 million
pounds I want to be a game where like I
could be number one and that game to me
was business in this conversation we
talk a lot about the Journey of
Entrepreneurship and we use temo's
background in starting these businesses
from when he was like 14 to starting fan
bites at the age of 21 and how that
ultimately sold for loads and loads and
loads of money a lot of people kind of
underestimate the power of both naivety
and youth and I think for a lot of young
people they almost do not realize how
many superpowers they have and we kind
of use that journey to tease out lessons
in entrepreneurship lessons in kind of
hustling a little bit to get what you
want through the third door we talk
about his journey of kind of meeting
people like Richard Branson at the age
of 17 despite not having any credentials
to his name I think it's incredibly
inspiring hearing how Timo had this
drive for entrepreneurship this drive to
start his own business and how he just
executed on it at a ridiculously young
age and then I think probably at 21
my dad passed away where I grew up if
you were coming home after 7 PM you
shouldn't do that I would try and make
friends with the gangsters because I
knew that at the very least if they saw
me in the evening they would be like oh
that's cool you know he's part of us and
hopefully you'll find in the
conversation some really practical
actionable advice if you're interested
in entrepreneurship but also hopefully
you'll appreciate how humble and
down-to-earth Timo is in his advice I
found it super super inspiring and I
hope you enjoy the conversation as much
as I did just a very quick thing before
we get started if you have not yet
subscribed to the podcast either on
YouTube or in your favorite podcast app
of choice then please do it really helps
us out a lot thank you so much for
coming on this is going to be a problem
interesting it's gonna be fun you are
sort of by any definition of the word
phenomenally successful at a very very
young age
um but what I found uh interesting is
that
um I guess I saw a few parallels between
you and me in that we both started to
build businesses when we were around
like 13 14 years old we're also both
into closer magic apparently I read on
the internet what was your what was your
interest in Magic and then we can talk
about the business stuff my interest in
Magic that's interesting because I've
actually spoken about that like twice so
you did some good research
um
I think it was so I think there were two
things first of all I really craved be
in the center of attention
I think that came with being an only
child
um
so the idea that you know I'd have
people even if it's like whatever five
people uh they come and they like see me
do this trick and they say oh my God
right
um that for me was quite an important
thing
um so
that's one and I think the second one
was also like figuring out like the
hacks behind things I've always been
very interested in figuring out how
things work and how right so you see the
output here but what were the different
inputs that went in and you know my my
um my career as a magician was not
particularly long uh uh it was basically
for a few shows and by shows I mean a
few shows to friends and family Max
15 30 people yeah but I think that I
really love just that feeling and I
think to some degree I kind of peddle
that I guess into like at school being
good at public weekend it was I think it
came back to this idea of like
wanting attention um
um
uh and yeah that's it how old were you
when you were doing the shows my first
ever won
in that short-lived career
um
this was in Ghana so this was when I was
like nine hmm yeah this isn't Ghana
because I remember my grandma in the
front in the front row yeah in her
garden uh so yeah this was in Ghana what
sort of Tricks were you doing how did
you put a show together just like just
like dumb things like oh here's a glass
oh there's no like it was just like like
really really like trivial things
um but it was all that I wanted people
to go oh you know wow like that's really
cool yeah and I'm pretty sure like they
all saw this this was not magic uh but
like to them or at least to me them
going wow it's kind of quite significant
I mean so I got into magic around age
17. so I would sort of peak attention
seeker back then how do I be cool at
school
I'm not any of the sports teams uh
getting good grades is not cool so let
me try to do these close-up magic yeah a
little bit more attention yeah way I
mean like if you really think about it
right like most of the things we do
whether it's business whether it's
public speaking whether it's Sports
where there's even like being good at
Academia like
fundamentally it comes down to like we
want to feel important right and so
magic in some way made us feel important
business in some way like everything
right when did you move to the UK uh
when I was 10 so I came here in year six
um fun story about that so I so I was
born here I was born in Hackney but then
I went to live in Ghana for 10 years and
when I came back here I'm in year six so
one of the really interesting things is
like um
in Ghana when you ask a question in
school you have to like
raise your hand and stand up right and
like in in here you don't have to do
that so my first I think now my first
week in school they asked a question
about like ratios and probabilities and
I knew the answer they asked me and I
like raised my hand and I stood up oh
and everyone was just like this flipping
nerd right so I had to spend about six
weeks kind of just doing that and then I
remember the day that I asked a question
and I didn't stand out from everyone I
was like oh my God this guy's a gangster
now uh uh yeah that was one of my kind
of uh
yeah weird memories one of my so I moved
uh here in year four and I was in uh
Lesotho for six years
um and so I I had this distinct memory
it was it was bizarre like walking to
Primary School on the first day we were
the only like brown people in the school
they're like full of white people and I
remember thinking just like whoa these
people are all like my skin color
because in Lesotho it's like I was the
whitest person there and then in the UK
I was like I didn't I didn't I didn't
clock I was like just completely baffled
but what was going on there yeah
um I I also made a few faux pas like um
so I was in school in in Lesotho for a
few years and then in Pakistan for a
year yeah and in both places if someone
was fat you would call them fat and it
was yeah totally normal just straight
and then in my in my year in in in in
year four there was this guy and I
called him fat and he is like yeah yeah
and the teacher called me and he was
like yeah it's really not nice and I
felt so bad I was just like but it's so
normal and it just it was only later
that I realized just how normalized some
of the experiences yeah yeah don't you
also find funny how I guess in the the
developing world how being blunt and
being open is just so
respected or so it's like well yeah
you're fat you're fat yeah go to the gym
don't eat that much done right whereas
here it's like you know yeah you know
maybe there's this reason it's not all
right mate but anyway yeah yeah
definitely I had to learn a lot of the
empathy compassiony type stuff at that
time but exactly um okay so you moved to
the UK age 10. um moved back to Hackney
or no I lived on the Oakland Road with
my dad so uh I just became a South
London boy
pretty much my whole life so where did
the interest in business come from uh
the interest in business came from
at 14 when I started my Tutoring company
and I actually did it not because
so I did I mean there's a story that
I've mentioned a few times but basically
like I was walking back home with my
friend we saw this black Mercedes-Benz
and you know like just this crazy events
right and basically he asked me how much
do you think that is and I was like oh I
think it's I don't know like 500 pounds
right just 14 no real concept of money
and I was like cool
um and he made his bet to me he said
like you wouldn't make 500 pounds before
you turned 18. because at that time we
thought you know 500 pounds it's like
you know 5 million right it's like what
the heck right because the context
behind this is like like
I lived in a like fourth floor counselor
stay on Oakland Road it was like money
wasn't a thing to me right I just like
oh cool you know maybe one day you know
I will be able to afford X right and so
he made that bet with me I then went
online and I was trying to find ways to
make money and I said it before but like
so I'm 27 now uh 13 years ago 13 years
ago if you search like how to make money
online it's just like fraudsters right
just like marketing affiliate marketing
Drop Shipping paid surveys there you go
there you go I mean even like even you
know Dropship is fine but it's like
those weird things like you know pay me
497 and I will teach you the secrets of
wealth and it's like well I don't have
497 that's why I'm coming to you
um uh so I started but what I did see
was a was a quote which said like work
with what you know and basically on that
day like
and I think if it hadn't happened on
that day I would not have started um the
company basically on that day I had done
pretty well in a math test and I was
like oh that's interesting like working
though you know I'm pretty good at maths
so then what I then said was why I'm
going to tutor people maths
um because the way that I like thought
about math was in the way we were taught
I figured out you know like just just
different like mental models um to use
and so I started and the next day I just
said right you know in the last test I
scored 100 in that
um I'm gonna show you guys how I did
that and so that was really the way that
I started getting my first
um Taste of business and then the
crucial point and you're probably gonna
notice the theme from not only this
business but entrepreneur Express and
then fan bites is I I basically like
built a bunch of businesses off like
connecting people so the way that it
worked was you know it was going well
with mats and then people come to me for
like physics and chemistry and all that
stuff and I'd be like well I don't I'm
not the best at that so what I do is I
go to the teachers and I'd ask them hey
um in the last exam who did the best at
that exam then they'll tell me yeah and
then I would then go to that person and
say hey you want to make some money
right because the whole model was you as
a tutor I would basically match you with
someone who needed some tutoring it
would be like 15 or 18 pound an hour
I'll take five you keep the rest and if
you're like a 14 15 16 year old that's
pretty good and so that was pretty much
like my first thing and I was like oh
like this is a business like people are
paying me for Value like this is an
actual thing how did you find your first
customer was it people in your year yeah
when they like kind of ripping the [ __ ]
out of you for having the audacity to
charge them for maths tutoring so I had
so I had basically built a brand in
secondary school as like being the smart
one okay and so as a consequence of that
like it's almost like if the smart
person comes to you and tells you like
you can be as smart as me
just pay me X you know it's kind of like
well yeah okay cool yeah um and so it
was relatively easy to get people at
that early stage because
like people just saw me as the smart
person okay um and where were these kids
getting money from foreign
money machined
um like the the the the Chinese kids in
my school just ah God bless them
yeah yeah I think I built my first
business off the back of Asian parents
hey I'm telling you they are the key
yeah
okay how how did it feel coming into 18
pounds an hour when you're that age and
500 pounds feels like the amount that
would get you uh expense so I don't
think it was quite the 18 pound an hour
I think it was when I had got the other
tutors in so I grew it to like 65 tutors
in like six weeks like all from your
school yeah Racket and I think it was
when I started to get those like five
pound commission checks whilst they kept
the rest
that was when I think that my mind just
went oh because like you know at 18
pound an hour it's like I'm helping you
you're paying me even when I was getting
like five pounds it was more like oh
like I've created something which is
working and like people are paying me
without me like having to do the direct
effort right and that was when I think
it kind of um tipped you know soon
enough I realized that a Benz doesn't
cost 500 an hour uh sorry um 500 pounds
um but I think that pivotal point of
like I created this thing it kind of
worked and now like stuff is happening
without me getting directly involved
that was a bit where I was like oh like
yeah this is a thing just a quick
announcement from one of our sponsors
and we'll get right back to the episode
and this episode is brought to you by
Heights Heights is a brain care smart
supplement that I've been taking every
morning for the last 12 months I love it
so much that I actually became friends
with the founder Dan who we actually had
on season one of the Deep dive podcast
we also have an interview this season
with neuroscientist and psychiatrist Dr
Tara swart who's the chief science
officer of heights and I like the
product so much that I actually became
an angel investor in the company it's
great everything they do is completely
evidence-based so on their website
they've got a list of all 20-something
micronutrients that they've got in these
two capsules along with links to all of
the various scientific papers and
consensuses on why these sorts of
nutrients are good for you and why
they've got them at the appropriate
dosing which they have in the capsules
in the capsules it's super easy to sign
up you just go on the website which is
linked in the show notes and in the
video description and you put in your
address and they send you one of these
little boxes of pills every month for
every quarter now I sign up to the
quarterly subscription so I get three of
these every three months and the
quarterly subscription is great because
a it's discounted from the monthly
subscription and B if you use the coupon
code Ali 15 ali15 at checkout then
you'll get an extra 15 off the already
discounted price of the quarterly
subscription now obviously it's ideal if
you can actually get all these
micronutrients from your diet that would
be the gold standard but as studies show
99 of us in the Western World don't in
fact have the absolutely perfect gold
standard Mediterranean diet I certainly
don't I eat a lot of takeaways and so
these two capsules just two capsules
Every Morning has my base is covered and
it's a lot easier to take just two
little capsules with water than it is to
try and drown green sludge or whatever
else other other companies have in the
market that kind of does the same thing
so anyway thank you so much Heights for
sponsoring this episode and let's get
right back to the podcast there's one
powerful moment of like when you first
earn money off your own back yeah um but
then the other one is where you do
something and it's just like oh [ __ ] I
just earned money while I was sleeping
yeah it was awesome yeah yeah remember
uh so when I was younger I used to do
sort of freelance web design and that's
how I would get kind of five pounds here
and there oh my God I'm making money off
my own back but then when I think when I
was like 15 I built this affiliate
marketing thing and one of my one of my
friends Godwin uh he got for his four
sisters to sign up to love film which is
like yeah old school Netflix back in the
day for a credit card and cancel it and
it was 12.50 each that's funny and while
I was on a school trip my mum rang me up
and she was like why do you have this
check for 50 pounds and it was one of
those checks that had like you know like
electronically printed so like how many
millions how many hundreds of thousands
there's like how many tens five I just
made 50 questions and I just built a
website and my mate signed up for these
fake fake accounts so that was the
moment for me that was like [ __ ] you can
build something on the Internet and it
will pay you while you're on a school
trip yeah um yeah I think that moment is
just
you know there's a LinkedIn posts I made
which
um did well which I said um
your first 100 pound is more significant
than your first million and people are
like wait what and I was like the type
of person that you have to become in
order to like make your first you know
bit of cash like through business
through blah blah
you know
from then on it really is a case of like
scaling and repeating and like putting
systems in place but I had a huge amount
of growth from let's say the first say a
thousand pounds yeah that I made to like
the first million that I made it was
like
it was like I had become the type of
person who creates value and I realized
how to create value so then it was a
case of me like figuring out what system
am I going to use what skill am I
actually going to be able um to use to
like scale my value
um so that's why I often say that people
go well it's so easy for you to say but
like it is actually a true statement
like you have to become a different
person in order to like be able to give
value to the world and get paid for it
you know yeah I think it's it's exactly
the same thing in YouTube like the first
thousand subscribers it like makes you a
completely different person yeah I'm
going to go from a thousand to a million
yeah more of the same yeah really like
just like do more of what works yeah
yeah I'm with you um the other thought I
had on this is um there's a really good
blog post I read that talks about the
idea of Shifting the goal posts and how
some people are like oh you know you
shouldn't shift the goal post like one
what back in the day earning 100K a year
would have been like freaking
mind-blowing and then you get to that
point you're like uh you know maybe like
10 million would be kind of nice
um but but the point of the blog post
was that this is not actually a sign of
like greed and capitalism yeah this is
just a sign that as you become the sort
of person who gets closer and closer to
making 100K a year your identity changes
yeah and now you realize that oh I
actually have the skills to be able to
make 100K yeah cool let's go for 10
million it's just in a way more of a
challenge more fun 100 it's not like
part of it is like oh yeah you know that
thing is fancier I'm hanging out with
the sorts of people who have money yeah
I am with you but also yeah
fundamentally the floor for how much you
can earn just completely changes yeah
yeah my um my co-founder on his
um on his phone he has something quite
cool and it says like how much is enough
uh and the reason why he asked himself
that question was because he started to
almost I think he started to forget the
value of just like
like what he's done in life right and at
some point he was like okay I'm just
perpetually going on this treadmill
um but it was also like a
self-enforced treadmill like no one
created the treadmill he just created it
and said well you know I've done this uh
27 28 because he's 28. well that should
therefore mean that at 35 I do blah
right it's like what are you doing man
so he just kind of did this as a as a um
reminded himself like how much is enough
I asked our mutual friend Dan Priestley
this question
um two days ago I asked Dan how do you
know I I think I phrased it like when is
enough enough and what he said he what
he said was really good he was like when
your aim is to make money for yourself
that's when you ask that question when
your aim is to provide impact and
service to the world you don't ask that
question yeah yeah I was like [ __ ]
you're right very true yeah very true
100 very true what's how's that you know
it was gonna I was gonna come on to this
afterwards when we talk about the exit
but like how how is your relationship
with enough changed over time
um one of the things I did when I knew
the exit was gonna happen was um I
actually asked other friends who had
been through an exit and I asked them
like how they fell after it and it was
funny there were like two camps one of
them was like man this was a great
stepping stone to go and do other stuff
and then some were like I've hit my
number and there's a phrase a lot of
them use was that like they've exited
the Matrix
and I found that such a profound phrase
to just say like right like they came
into the game they play the game and now
everything that they do is just like
um optional upside and I think that's
kind of the camp that I'm in I think you
know at 27 I've been able to with you
know skill hard work but also a ton of
luck
um I have been able to achieve an exit
I've been able to achieve an outcome
where I was like wow
um
I can now everything I do from now is
like optional upside rather than feeling
like I have to do anything whereas
beforehand I think I always I always
operated from a position of like I had
to do this and now I'm just like I
choose to do this now
um which is very very different do you
think for someone someone listening to
this who hasn't had a life-changing exit
do you think you need to have that
before you can shift that mindset or is
it a thing that you could have
theoretically come to without having
yeah X whatever that number is like yeah
so I think um so I think that you can at
any point like
so I think that you can at any point
decide to do it from a position of I
guess like choice and optionality but I
do think that you do need like some kind
of forcing function as in
I think everyone
comes to that point at some point in
their lives it's just that like some
things that happen accelerate that right
um like at 27 selling the company for
like tens of millions it's like okay I
could probably have gone to that um and
go if I was you know by the time I was
50 but I've just been able to do it like
way earlier right
um
so I think people can get to that and go
it's just more a case of um like is
there a forcing function that gets you
there faster
just a quick message from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by short form short form
is the world's best service that
summarizes books but it's way more than
just book summaries they almost have a
whole study guide for every book that
they've got on the platform where
they've got a one-page summary and then
they also have chapter by chapter
breakdowns and it's not just chapter by
chapter breakdowns also in between the
chapter breakdowns they have interactive
exercises where you can engage more
readily with the ideas in the book short
form covers non-fiction books from a
bunch of different genres that you might
be interested in for example they've got
a load of stuff in the business world so
if for example you're an entrepreneur or
you want to become an entrepreneur
that'll be great for you they've got
books in motivation they've got books in
education they've got books and
lifestyle and communication basically
any genre of like non-fiction personal
development is self-helpy stuff that
will help you level up your life it's
all there on short form short form
Publishers new book guides and articles
every week and if you're a subscriber
then you get to vote on what book they
cover next and in fact through that
system I have voted for various books
that they've then turned into summaries
for example one of the books I recently
Revisited on short form is traction by
Gino Wickman now traction is all about
the entrepreneurial operating system and
I have listened to the audiobook of
traction like twice I've read the
physical book of traction like twice but
it's just so dense and so filled with
practical actionable insights that
actually revisiting the book using short
form was super helpful in helping me
realize oh hang on that's how you should
run a level 10 meeting or oh hang on
that's what we need to do with our
accountability chart anyway if any of
that sounds up your street and you would
like to sign up to the world's best
service that summarizes books then head
over to shortform.com forward slash Deep
dive and that will give you a completely
free five-day trial and you can try out
the service to your heart's content that
link will also be in the video
description and in the show notes and
thank you so much short form for
sponsoring this episode I know a few
people for whom that forcing function
was
a major health scare or like a
near-death experience where you're like
oh my God yeah I'm so grateful to be
alive everything is optional upside down
and that to me is just like okay cool
but it will like that that's an
alternative way to get off that yeah I
was talking to um Dan Priestley about
this as well
um there's a book called the second
Mountain
um it's by this yeah this guy um David
Brooks I think uh where the first
mountain is that mountain of success and
happiness and freedom and status and
stuff and then either you get to the top
and you realize huh okay or you get
knocked off the mountain by a health
scare or by a near-death experience or
something like that and you realize
there's another mountain and that's the
mountain of like joy and service and
purpose and Mission and devoting
yourself to a cause you care about and
yeah the more like I choose to do this
rather than I have to do this yeah yeah
there you go forcing function forcing
function yeah
um okay so what happened with alpha
alpha tutoring oh uh that they're
flopped um so he had 65 tutors yeah the
reason that it flopped is actually a
lesson in Disguise so
with tutoring when you're effectively
the Matchmaker especially in tutoring is
that like if you match a tutor to a 2T
what happens is they've they create a
really good relationship a really good
connection which therefore means that
there's no impetus for them to come back
to you yeah so what happened was you
know all those like commissions I was
getting they were just like dwindling
and I was like what the heck is going on
and it's fundamentally because the
parents are like well I like Tom Tom's a
good tutor therefore I'm just going to
keep Tom right and Tom also has no
incentive to let Tim know right that
he's that um that you know Tim he's the
five pounds yeah so um so uh so that
business basically kind of like didn't
go anywhere but it taught me two things
first of all was that I could just
create value all right I could use
almost from nothing create something and
people pay me for it but it also taught
me about
um wanting to like own the entire
infrastructure yeah and like that got me
into the whole like you know programming
stuff and everything yeah
um and then yeah that's that's that that
was it and I think
the first point about like having that
point of realization that you can just
create value was just like oh and and it
was like that's what I want to do for
the rest of my life basically what
happened with business number two
business number two was my first ever
exit um it was a company called
entrepreneur Express I was really
interested in you know business and all
that stuff uh so I created a and
actually at that time I was also the
editor-in-chief of my school magazine
and so
um I basically started like uh
publication which was all around like
business entrepreneurship because my
whole thing was I really enjoy business
I really enjoy reading my business
understanding it Etc maybe there's other
people who care about it and I can turn
into some kind of business and so the it
was both an online and offline magazine
um and the reason I wanted to be offline
was because at that point as I mentioned
I was like the editor-in-chief of my
school magazine so there was something
cool about having like a physical print
right so I actually called up a bunch of
like the university so like Oxford
Cambridge why work LSC I called up there
like um like entrepreneur societies I
was like hey you know next year
do you want to take this publication Etc
they're like yeah because of course it
was free for them so duh
um they just do it
um and then what ended up happening was
probably around August so the term
started like September
around August I was like oh crap I need
advertising okay right because I hadn't
like thought through the economics of
how I will sustain the actual business
okay it was just like here's a cool
magazine we've got this interview so
like great entrepreneurs I managed to
get an interview Like Richard Branson
James Khan Alan sugar
um actually here's a fun story this is a
great story actually I don't think I've
actually mentioned a story before inside
skip yeah so this this actually yeah
however not mentioned the story before
anyway so
um so I've done all these interviews
blah blah and I want to get like a big
hitter right and there was this um event
called like like business live something
it's like business life something and it
was in the Excel Arena so this was about
10 years ago and they got a James Khan
Alan sugar Richard Branson to come and
do like keynote speaks right I was like
I really want to be part of it I really
want to be in like the Press room and
just like speak to them because I know
if I can have like an interview with
these guys that would just be crazy
um but obviously I didn't know like how
I'd get their press passes Etc
so what I did was I emailed
um the like the owner of the event
Vishal great guy and I said hey so I'm
this 17 year old I don't you know
I don't have the contacts I don't have
the kind of credibility to be backstage
but
how about if I come the day before and I
basically lay out all the chairs I lay
out all the chairs I lay out all the
tables I lay out all that stuff and all
you do is you give me a backstage pass
that's it right because the hymn is
actually a perfect win it's like he
doesn't have to pay someone else
um and he doesn't have to spend that
much time on it's like okay this random
kid is just gonna do it and he was like
Yeah Okay cool so the day before the
business live I remember that I showed
up like 1pm or something and I just lay
out like all the chats just just taking
them out there I checked them in order
okay they're in order I did all of that
I did all of that and and Vishal choose
his word
um the next day I found myself backstage
with um with uh Branson in fact on the
front cover of our first ever
entrepreneur Express thing is a picture
of Branson um speaking
um so I was backstage there and then
there was like a back room of the
backstage and again Vishal was like yeah
you can come in so we were then able to
have like 15 minutes each with
um uh Branson sugar con Etc
um Khan was quite sure was like five
minutes but um a few other songs just
like Coco got that and then I turned it
into an interview
um
and there's something very cool now that
I think about it I've often thought that
like and I know that your audience has
uh quite a lot of um young people and
aspiring people I think a lot of people
kind of underestimate the power of both
naivety and youth right like
I don't think anyone you know people
would have seen that all right he can't
get a backstage pass so just go oh well
I guess I can't right but like my hack
was I'm actually going to figure out
what I can bring to the table which is
just like energy and time and I'm just
gonna you know bring that to the table
and fish also there was like yeah cool
and I think for a lot of young people
they almost do not realize
how many superpowers they have in terms
of just like energy time and naivety and
that really helped me when doing
entrepreneur Express
um because I just didn't know what I
shouldn't do and so therefore I just did
stuff that seemed logical to me
um yeah nice that's sick there you go
that that's such a great story I I can't
believe it's the first time you've told
me yeah yeah two thoughts on that the
first is
you know as as I'm sure you do like I
get tons and tons of emails from
generally young people asking for stuff
and like zero percent of them offer
something in return yeah yeah they never
say like what I can do for you they're
always just like hey will you give me an
iPhone will you give it like oh I need
an iPad for school would you give me an
iPhone better yeah apparently anyone who
does Tech videos on YouTube just gets
inundated with emails being like Oh you
know I'm really trying to get an iPhone
and it's like literally no one emails
saying that hey here's what I can offer
you in return and it's almost so easy to
say yes to something if there's actually
yeah you know time to lay out these
chairs of course I'm going to say yes to
that like why wouldn't I say yeah so
what do you think it was about you that
that instead of saying oh I can't get a
backstage pass whatever it's not for me
you took that extra step of being like
you know what why don't I just email the
owner of this event yeah and offer to
freaking stack some jazz
so this actually something I've been
thinking about recently about something
that shaped my youth and I think it's I
always behaved like I was special
like I always always behaved like I just
had something like special and different
about me and so when I saw that
conference business life it was almost
like
there was not a conceivable World in
which I was not able to interview those
guys it was like
I could almost see myself in the room
already interviewing them so it was just
a case of I just had to make it happen
and I think
if it wasn't the chairs maybe I would
have you know like dressed up as a
security person and like got in like I
would have figured out a way in
um and I think I had always I think that
General mentality of like well
it's gonna happen we just have to figure
out how it happened
um is one of those things that has
served me quite well but I also then
started to assume that like everybody
needs something right and so you just
have to be the person to give it to them
right if you're like you know Vishal and
you're doing this big conference like
you probably don't you know yeah you
need money that's why you're charging
people for it I can't give you that but
the other thing that you need is time
right and so I can give you time and to
some degree I can save you money by just
doing the chat so one of the things that
I've always kind of used one of the
Frameworks that I've always just used um
generally is like
how do I give this other person what
they want right and I need to uncover
what they want
um because you know because by giving
them what they want they could also when
time comes like they could give me what
I want and it's not in some kind of
transactional way it's more like
everyone needs something right
um
especially just like over time you know
where there is my investors whether it's
like people that I've worked with and
all that stuff like I've come to realize
that you know everyone has some sort of
problem that it kind of won't fix it
could be a very small one like one of my
very close friends he's just like uber
successful I you know the guy who were
talking about before
um we we
um started this pod when I was talking
to him was like oh um my best friend's
knee is hurting and I was like oh okay I
actually know a very good osteopath so
then like I couldn't help him with more
money and stuff like the guys worth like
2 billion right he's like what can
happen but I can help him by helping his
friend and then in that way like further
down the line if I need some help with
something he'd help me right so I think
those two beliefs like really helped me
and they come up across a book called uh
the the go-giver no so there's a book I
started reading yesterday um it was
another podcast guest who recommended it
and actually one of our team members uh
bought the book ages ago for me because
he was like I think this is how you do
business
um and it's like a little tiny tiny
little book which is a parable about
this guy who's like really struggling in
business and then he meets this Mentor
Mentor basically the Five Laws of
Success this guy's describing oh he's a
real go-getter he's but then he's really
struggling with his business yeah he's
his mentor this old guy and the Five
Laws of Success and all of it is based
around giving just giving yeah giving
yeah yeah and it's like the more you
give the more you can find ways to add
value to others in a non-transactional
way yeah not keeping score the more
inevitably yeah just everything goes
your way just like Good Karma and stuff
right
um yeah so that's basically how I got to
interview to Branson I just realized
that we're talking about the second cup
video It's Like Richard Branson give it
all right
yeah yeah there's another there's
another thing that sparked in my mind um
have you have you come across a book
called the third door
no oh let's just say like it's a this is
I think your I'd be curious to get your
take on it um it's a book by uh Alex
bernayan in fact I'm gonna grab it so I
can read this out
this is live folks exactly
I know it's not pre-recorded
the third door this is sick um the wild
quest to uncover how the how the world's
most successful people launched their
careers all right okay Incredible Book
um basically it's a guy who's like 20 21
he was like I don't know what to do with
my life so he made it his life's mission
to interview people like Richard Branson
and stuff and find find out what they
did at age 21 to get ahead yeah
um and here is why it's called to the
third door life business it's just like
a nightclub there are always three ways
in there's the first door the main
entrance where 99 of people wait in line
hoping to get in the second door is the
VIP entrance through which the
billionaires and celebrities slip
through but what no one tells you is
that there is always the third door it's
the entrance where you have to jump out
of line run down the alley bang on the
door a hundred times crack open the
window and sneak through the kitchen
there's always a way in whether it's
Bill Gates selling his first piece of
software or Steven Spielberg becoming
the youngest Studio director in
Hollywood history they all took the
third door
I like that yeah I feel like this very
much Vibes with your approach to you
know I like that the way you got into
interview Richard Branson is through the
third door you want standing in line you
want an acute waiting for his autograph
you were just like how do I get in in a
somewhat unconventional way I like that
okay well there you go the third door so
I took the third door you took the third
door okay so you interview so you
interview Brunson Khan Alan sugar what
happens next yeah so did that blah blah
anyway uh so the so I got all these
interviews sorry I got all these
universities lined up to take the
magazine and all that stuff
um and then I just realized I could not
sell that much advertising because I had
the money for the first publication but
for the subsequent stuff I just knew
that I would uh struggle to actually
like turn it into a business
so then I turn my attention to the
online version and it was the online
version that I just put all my time into
and and that's why I say you know part
of it was luck but I think most of it
was like you know skill was I figured
out you know this was 10 years ago and I
was yeah
this was like the Heyday of uh Facebook
pages and Facebook accounts and all that
stuff so I use these Facebook pages to
drive traffic to the online site and
that was the way that I basically made
all the money was that I'd I'd upload
like banner ads I'd tie into all of
these like programmatic ad exchanges
um and then I just make money from the
eyeballs
um and then within 11 months I got an
email and the email was basically
someone from an agency called Horizon
media which is based in the US and they
were like hey we'd like to partner up
with you
and you know again I'm 17 someone's like
yeah partner up I'm like yeah okay yeah
all right see and they said um
can we do a Skype right this was this
shows you you know 10 years ago Skype uh
they were like yeah it came to Skype and
and then said before that can you share
some of your like stats Etc because
I thought they were more just like an
agency who wanted to sell ads on my site
right you know standard stuff so I sent
over my stats Etc and then they said hey
um rather than partner up we just like
to buy you and
and I tell the story a lot and even you
know now I tell it I kind of get
goosebumps because I'm like I remember
that was like a Friday 2 A.M I was
wearing my man united shorts and like
someone had just said right this thing
you've been working on for 11 months we
would like to buy it and I was in school
then right and because I went to
boarding school for um six four
and I was there and it was like
oh my God like a what does this mean
when you say bye because you're American
does that mean that I didn't have to go
to you I was talking about that stuff
um and I was like yeah sure yeah sounds
good
um and then within a week within about
two weeks you're done I had transferred
uh the site to them admin login uh
Facebook pages all that stuff
transferred to them and like that was
the first time that I'd made like
serious money the fee was 70 grand and
then over a year which ended up being
like 15 months over 15 months consistent
payouts over traffic so in all the total
sum was like 110 Grand and I was just
like I've worked on this for 11 months
and I'm 17. I was like how did that
happen so that was the first one where I
was like oh this [ __ ] is Magic like this
business [ __ ] is Magic
um yeah so you're 17 you just made like
100 Grand yeah crazy by selling a
website under some Facebook pages to
some American company yeah it's so
interesting right because you know they
they so their whole plan with Horizon
media was to build a bunch of these like
Niche blogs right so their own blogs and
food support business Etc turns out that
kind of flopped and now they're just
like an agency right but like yeah it
was crazy it was crazy and I think at
that point I was just like
again it just reinforced this idea of
just like
inventing things from scratch I said wow
like this happens and I remember going
to my dad and like telling him about it
and he was like oh so like that's what
you've been doing all night
um uh uh yeah it's crazy
how did how did that feel when the money
hit your account
I felt invincible
I fell but I also felt like I discovered
a cheat sheet like
this was no funding nothing at all I
used my like skills and my brains to
like figure out how things work so I
think I just felt like I had discovered
a cheat sheet to life and I then thought
like I'm just gonna dedicate myself to
figuring out
um this cheat sheet even more and more
and more
um
as I mentioned like that that 100k
was more significant
than the exit in like tens of millions
and I tell people then they go like what
I'm like yeah because
it was like I did that you know like I
did that and in such a short period of
time I did that so yeah it was pretty
profound
how did you
have time to do all this stuff while
also being in school
I did not really do school properly so I
went to so I went to a secondary school
uh but then in sorry I went to a state
secondary school but then in uh sixth
form I went to a boarding school so I
went to a boarding school called Christ
Hospital hated it passionately hated it
because I I born in school is not for me
um and it's so funny there was actually
a joke in the school I had a name called
like Tim the rules don't apply armor
because they come up with like all these
kind of like rules about you know you
have to be in bed by this time you have
to do this at this time and I just
wouldn't do it at all I just constantly
asked why why why
um so I think mentally
actually I'll tell you the big mindset
shift so remember earlier that I said
that in school I had basically like
built a brand of being the smart one hmm
um when I went to Christ Hospital
everyone there was insanely clever I
remember there's a guy
um Luke Stevens Luke Stevens was 15 and
had finished his like
like further maths and he's and he got
like 100 like this guy was genius level
right and there were quite a few people
like that so I kind of realized that I
couldn't win the game of intelligence at
Christ hospital so therefore the one
game that I could win was that like I
was more entrepreneurial than those guys
like I was more business savvy than um
those guys
so to answer your question about like
how I manage the time it was actually
like in my mind I was then like an
entrepreneur first and then a student
second because I knew I couldn't win the
like student game of like you know like
get Greek no just good grades they're
like yes I got good grades I went to
Warwick I did a computer science degree
blah blah blah but like
I didn't care about winning that game
enough I want to be a game where like I
could be number one and that game to me
was business so that's why I didn't like
spend all my time primarily on that and
then I kind of became a student second
was that a conscious thing or is that
like kind of connecting the dots looking
back oh 100 I actually remember I had a
notebook in Christ hospital and I
remember writing that like okay
this guy funny again it is not something
that I've shared publicly but it's like
I wrote people's names down who were
like academically smarter than me and
then I wrote like where can I win right
and you know I was like Luke Francis
samshaw like really really you know
intelligent people I was like hmm But
none of them are entrepreneurial none of
them are like business savvy none of
them are like that
um I want to win in a game and I want to
be number one in a game
um so that was a very conscious decision
where I thought yeah like this is
something that I need to win this game
just a quick note from one of our
sponsors and we'll get right back to the
episode and this episode is very kindly
brought to you by skillshare if you
haven't heard by now skillshare is one
of the world's leading Platformers for
online classes for online education
they've got thousands and thousands of
classes on all sorts of topics from
business entrepreneurship lifestyle
design cooking interior design loads of
stuff and very excitingly I have
actually been teaching on skillshare
since 2019 and I've got 13 classes on
skillshare yes 13 classes and you can
access all of them completely free of
charge by going to skillshare.com
forward slash Deep dive and that link
will give you a free one month trial to
skillshare during which you can watch
any and all of my classes now if for
example you happen to be a student or
you're just interested in lifelong
learning then I've got two classes on
skillshare that I've taught that you
might be interested in the first one is
my how to study for exams evidence-based
tips study class and that basically
compiles every single thing that I've
ever learned and that the research shows
on what are the most evidence-based and
effective ways of studying for your
exams and I also have a class on
skillshare around how to use Anki which
is the world's most popular flashcard
app which you can use for studying for
exams but also for learning languages
for learning music theory things like
that and loads of people have taken that
class and said that that class was so
good that they would have literally paid
hundreds of dollars for it but you get
it completely for free on skillshare by
going to skillshare.com forward slash
Deep dive after your trial is over you
can choose to continue the subscription
if you like and you can access the
thousands of classes skillshare house
from other teachers including people
that I know people I'm friends with like
Thomas Frank and Nathaniel Drew but yeah
the main reason to check out skillshare
of course is that you want to check out
my classes if you want to learn about
productivity and video editing and
youtubing and even cooking so head over
to skillshare.com forward slash Deep
dive and thank you so much skillshare
for sponsoring this episode what sort of
the setbacks did you have kind of I I
guess sort of through up until sort of
age 17 18 at this point like what was
going on in life
where I grew up
as I mentioned I grew up on like joking
Road
um this is when in like the peak of the
beef between like Oak and Road and
Peckham and Brixton so basically like if
you were coming home after 7 P.M you
shouldn't do that
yeah yeah yeah the ends were crazy mate
uh
and it was so funny like I would try and
make friends with the gangsters because
not because I wanted to become a
gangster [ __ ] that
um because I knew that at the very least
if they saw me in the evening they would
be like oh that's cool you know he's
part of us right so I think that was a
major setback was like the area that I
grew up in and knowing I didn't belong
there that was it like you know every
day I'd walk down to school in these
Council blocks and everything else and
I'd be like I don't belong here I don't
belong here I don't belong here
um
that was definitely a big setback
um
yeah like the general environment was a
setback living with my dad
just us
I didn't really have like a proper kind
of nuclear family that was a setback
um and then I think probably at 21 my
dad passed away and that was a major
setback that even drove my sense of like
I need to do something significant even
more how did your dad die he died of a
stroke really yeah and here's a crazy
thing I found him dead
yeah in his room and the crazy thing is
literally two three weeks before that
when we were kind of starting fan bites
he was like I don't know what you're
doing but I'm so proud of you well done
Etc
um and it's funny when I stood up in
front of the company
did you know Fanboys we grew to like 70
people and all that stuff when I when I
stood up in front of the company you
know I'd kind of rehearsed a talk Etc
and then at the end I was like
and another reason why we did this was
because
before we started fan bites before
probably started fan lights my dad
passed away
and when he passed away he said he was
very proud of me and I basically told
myself that there was no conceivable
World in which this business was not a
success and so because of that is the
reason why like
this had to happen right this business
had to have a successful outcome
and I think that subtly drove me a lot
just like it needed to be significant it
needed to not have like a you know like
an okay exit it needed to be like like
sick exit you know yeah wow
what do you think you're a dad would say
if if you were you know well he still
wouldn't understand what I did
um uh like well he's selling ads though
okay
Instagram uh
I think you just say exactly what he
said like the 2E for a pass away which
is I don't understand but I'm incredibly
proud of you
um and I think you'd also say I knew
this was going to happen
I think he would
um I think he always knew
something would happen
he doesn't know what all right
um yeah so I think that's quite a Big
Driver
yeah it sounds like he was like pretty
supportive while you're in this yeah
yeah yeah 100
um which is very different to most
African parents oh yeah yeah that's it
plus I've been friends are like you know
education etc etc and probably an Asian
Prince as well right but um but I think
he was like that at the beginning and
then he was just like I just don't get
this guy but at 17 he sold a business
and he's helping out with like stuff in
the house so continue
when you say you felt like you didn't
belong when you were when you were on
the streets in the end yeah what do you
mean by you didn't belong
I thought I was smarter than them
and I just felt like the stuff I was
interested in they were just not
interested
I'd spent a lot of time reading this
blog called
retire21.com oh okay an incredible blog
um and had reading I'd just be like man
look at all these cool people right at
that point Mashable was quite big so I'd
read it by you know P Cashmore I'd read
about all these people and go man this
is so cool and they were just interested
in like riding out to the ends and like
going to Peckham to [ __ ] stab people
and I was just like
I'm just not interested in am I
um there's actually again a side note
there's actually a LinkedIn post I also
did which was which the headline was
this was the day that a gangster saved
my life and it was because I wanted to
be you know part of the kids there you
know part of part of cool kids
um so that I could be you know like safe
and all that stuff
and one of the gangsters there guy
called Mike's he actually like took me
aside and said this ain't for you bro
and I was like well I was like no it is
it's like nah this ain't for you because
I think like he even realized that my
heart was not in it I cared more about
like business and intellectual stuff
um
and I remember when he said that I was
like mate if the lead gangster knows
right but this is not for me that is not
for me mate but yeah that's that's what
I felt but like I didn't belong
um
I just felt my interests were different
the pathway and was different yeah what
would you say to someone who might be
listening to this and feeling like
they're in that position wherever
wherever they are that they're in an
environment where they feel like they
don't belong and
yeah so I think the first thing I'd say
is like Embrace a difference I think too
many people try and like shun their
difference but like embracing your
difference is probably the first thing
and then almost
realize that like
being different creates different
outcomes right like by definition if you
want to do like extraordinary things you
can't be ordinary right because because
the word is literally extraordinary I
have uh so I think they'll probably be
the main thing which is like embrace
your difference and also realize that
like even if you feel even if you feel
different there are other people who
also feel different so find those people
who also feel different and just be like
different together right the way I did
that was when I was younger I was part
of you know like Reddit forums where
people would just be you know continue
my business and marketing and internet
marketing and funnels and all that stuff
and like that's where I just found my
joy and I was like oh my God yeah like
Russell Brunson is just dropped this
thing oh my God it's so sick you know uh
whatever
um who else all those people right I'll
say oh my God this is so sick all right
if you create this funnel and then you
put it in like a tripwire and there you
do this oh my God it's amazing right and
then I'd go out and it's like gang music
right and but I found my tribe with
people who cared about being different
as well
yeah I remember I remember signing up to
Russell brunson's mailing list back when
I was like 14 and just sort of I was
looking through my Gmail my Gmail
because I just Auto archived it just
like sort of like 10 or 13 years worth
of emails from Russell Brunson yeah
stuff
he was the OG though man he was he was
OG a lot of us owe a lot of our success
to discovering funnels and going wow
this whole world is just insane
all right so that was the entrepreneur
Express yes
um Arc The Arc and then you get to
University I get to University what
happens next uh get to University in my
second year I start fan bites and uh fan
bites the whole thing is really when I
sold entrepreneur Express I came to
realize that the thing that the buyer
was buying yeah you know was the was the
blog and everything but was also like
the the network of Facebook pages and
all that stuff I was like oh that's
where the value is so then what we
decided to do was I thought right I'm
going to build a company in this space
in the whole like influencer space and
helping Brands to reach that audience
and I specifically focused there on that
gen Z audience because well the reason
why I did was twofold firstly it's an
audience that I understood and it's also
an audience where I knew that we could
have a Competitive Edge
um so I remember that discussion in uh
saying you know why not just be broadly
influenced I was like trust me by saying
that we are for these people it means
that we can actually increase more the
value of the thing that we are providing
the service and so that was the
beginning of fan bites and within yeah
five and a half years Grew From then
from zero to 70 people
um and then we sold it so let's let's go
let's rewind talk about so you're in
your second year yeah what are the dots
that connect in your mind to think let
me start an influencer marketing thingy
for Gen Z's in the space and call it fan
Vite well I mean the first one was yeah
like
haven't saw the previous business and
seeing that the value lay in the
Facebook communities and the Facebook
pages which the acquire bought
um I was like it is all about social
okay
um the second one was
anytime there is a new frontier of
people or like a new paradigm like
Brands and companies would always want
help in being able to navigate that
whether it's radio TV uh Google ads
Billboards right like Brands would
always want a way to actually tap into
that and then the Gen Z thing was just
where is my Competitive Edge in doing
that and the fact that you were familiar
with agenda audience there you go the
second point the sort of recognizing the
sort of B2B yeah and appreciating that
yeah I think that is a leap that
certainly I didn't have because I was
always b2cu education business trying to
get Asian parents to pay for courses and
stuff and it was only many years later
as we started the YouTube channel and
started to get brand deals and stuff
even now to this day I still you know I
I'll I speak to another entrepreneur
friend who's like yeah a company like
notion should be paying you 100K a month
and I'm just like wait what yeah and he
was like you have no idea how valuable
this audience is like these guys [ __ ]
tons of money like and I'm still in b2c
mindset how did you get that sort of
kind of firmware update in your mind
that helped you realize there are
companies with large amounts of money
willing to pay for this thing
so I think I had seen it before right
like
I was very aware of like the agency game
you know I was just very people like wpp
and Mediacom and all these big
holding companies so I was just like
whoa brands are paying them to Market
their stuff to people so wacon branches
pay us to do it to this like specific
set of people and was that through there
being part of subreddits and like the
marketing world and stuff like because
again that was an area of the world that
I'd never come across before and I think
of it maybe it could be the fact that
when I when I sold entrepreneur Express
to Horizon
I realized at that point how like big
Horizon was and I was like
who the heck is paying all these guys
and then I think that was that got me
into like oh okay so like brands are
paying them to do blah blah blah so
therefore if I could do that for a
subset of people then you'd win
interesting so you know you've um become
super wealthy off the back of social
media marketing agency Stephen got super
wealthy on the back of social media
marketing agency let's say someone's
listening to this they're familiar with
yours and Stephen Butler stories and
they're thinking oh social media
marketing sounds good smma or whatever
the acronym for that is how should like
a would you recommend that as a business
model for someone today and B if so or
if not like how would someone get
started in that area I don't think that
so I think a big part of our success
when we came to so
take a few sets back so
when we decided that actually fan bites
need to become part of uh you know the
company to sell the company we had like
four different companies one to buy fan
blinds right and so because we had like
those four different companies you know
we were in a position of like strength
Etc but one of the things that I did
realize was that um they were all buy-in
because they wanted to integrate social
media and influencers into their wider
marketing uh pool right so it's like
okay we can do TV we can do Billboards
we can do all that stuff
um and so that was always the reason for
uh for any acquisition
so I say that as a precursor to say that
I don't think it makes sense at the
moment
to start a social media agency
um I think that the kind of tidal wave
has gone
um
and the reason why I say the Title Wave
is gone is because like for most of us
who did well
we basically kind of like rode the wave
of people not understanding something
and then applying tech services and all
that stuff to help them understand it
um right now I think most people
understand it yeah and so you have to
figure out a new way which people don't
like fundamentally understand if you
want to be in like the services business
um
I get a lot of people coming to me and
saying right you know I want to start a
social media industry and I'm like hey
like don't do that and B if you were to
do that what part of social media do
Brands don't like fully understand start
like an influencer business now
yeah like you can't turn into something
significant like you could turn into you
know a nice kind of like
cool thing that pays you and hires a few
people but like to build a business to
the level that we did to to let you know
think about people like lad Bible right
a lot of Bible were like the ogs of the
space like the Dons of this space right
and they've taken that business
incredibly done very well but they rode
the wave and you're not going to be able
to achieve that degree of success
if you start now because most of the
problems have been solved
yeah I think that's the thing with
like all of these businesses you know
even gymshark being OG influencer
marketing sort of people like back in
the day where it was still a bit Rogue
it was still a bit a bit a bit weird to
do that and so there's so much Alpha
there's so much Edge you have when you
have an insight into the market that
other people don't exactly and if those
people have money and are old then you
can win as a young person with that
level of Market inside but now it's so
if someone says to a brand you should be
marketing on Instagram
Sarah Tom Tanya and all these people are
dedicated to this all right in-house
right so it's like why would we need you
um
because one thing I've noticed like
generally in business is especially in
kind of like B2B kind of services
businesses it's like people are paying
you for the expertise right and the and
the depth of that expertise is directly
correlated to the Gap and the gap
between where they are and where they're
trying to be yeah so if for example you
come in and say like right I can do I
don't know let's take the example of
Instagram it's like well cool
I could pay for it but the gap between
me as a brand not being good at
Instagram and then being good is quite
small if you said in 2017 like I can
figure out you know
um I can help you like build and own a
YouTube channel like people don't know
how to do that right so they're starting
from here they want to get here the
gapage is bigger which therefore means
like you can charge generally more
um so I think it's always important if
you're thinking about you know like
business and where should I play that
you want to think about like how big is
that Gap in the problem because that's
the way that you're truly going to win
do you think that that Gap is still a
thing on YouTube I think building owned
and operated channels on YouTube yes it
is I think marketing on there not really
yeah like everyone does YouTube ads but
like yeah it's we've had so much
interest from people who are like [ __ ] I
know I should be on YouTube we should
have a brand presence on YouTube itself
but they don't know where to start yeah
I think there's the opportunity for
Brands to do that the big thing with
YouTube though is like
so one of the other things that I think
about is like how soon can someone get a
payoff so I'll tell you like a big
inflection point with fan bites was when
we really focus on like the ROI that we
provide to Brent and the thing is you
know fundamentally if a brand is
spending 100 Grand it's not for fights
right
um so they spend that money to make sure
that like they can earn um XYZ the the
thing with YouTube is like
it can take a lot of time relatively a
lot more time to build and owned an
operated audience and so as a
consequence of that like it can also
take a lot of time to see the payoff so
you so you almost need to like figure
out a way in which like you can reduce
the time to pay off right because if you
can't do that then you win if it takes
long then you just need patience from
the brand side or from the creative side
which can yeah which can be a hustle
yeah this is some stuff like uh Alex
hormozi talks about this a lot like
reducing this time to Value all right
reducing the amount of like people will
pay astronomically more for a service
that is quick yeah compared to a service
that takes ages yeah which is why like
supplements is like 100 times bigger
than Fitness because Fitness takes time
and supplements doesn't it anything that
promises a quick fix yeah and if you can
actually deliver on that quick fix yeah
you're just yeah laughing all the way to
the bank and you're winning exactly
um
what did the growth in terms of yeah how
so so you started in your second year
what was the growth trajectory of fan
bites in terms of I guess
maybe you can't share Revenue but like
sort of Team size and stuff like you
share the first three years of yeah
uh because I think that's interesting uh
first year 400 Grand second year one
million so uh third year 1.7
okay what are what were the margins on
this back in the day like you're making
400 Top Line like how much are you how
much goes into your bank account
oh first year we made a loss
how because we were just stupid at
spending money like as in
the first year all we did was we were
just trying to get on as many case
studies as possible and so with Brands
we'd like overspend we wouldn't take any
right real margin on it because we knew
the value of the case studies so hang on
so the brand would pay you let's say 50k
and would you put that into by the way
first year we were not driving through
the game mate oh okay fine I brought a
Pete like 5K
and what are you doing with that 5K are
you putting into ads or hiring an
influencer like what was yours so we're
defining what like the influencer
campaign should be and then afterwards
yeah we're like paying out to
influencers we're paying for ads and all
that stuff but our whole thing was like
we just wanted to get really good case
studies and also bear in mind like in
our first year we had raised a bit of
money okay and we're also in University
and so we didn't need to like
necessarily you know like make profit
right yeah um through the Grand skin
business we raise 2 million for the
business yeah yeah so we'd raise a bit
of money then we raised a bit of money
in the second year as well which meant
that we still didn't really need to make
a profit and then third year we made a
big profit so the loss that you made was
build basically eating into the investor
money yeah because you wanted to what
was this intentional were you like
Brands paying us 5K we're going to spend
10K because we want a really good case
study or was it just accidental how
you're like oh [ __ ] we paid too much it
was intentional oh okay it was
intentional
um because we're like you know we have
cash so let's just like focus on just
revenue and case studies that was it
that was very intentional as well like
the first two years was very much like
we want to grow grow grow and not care
about profit yet and then you know
fourth year we cared about profit fifth
year we definitely cared about profit so
who was we at the time myself and my
co-founder Ambrose and then we hired a
CTO okay
um and then yeah first year we're like
five people second year probably eight
third year probably
20. were you like paying your own
salaries like how are you yeah we were
paying ourselves like 500 pounds a month
but then paying actual people like two
grand a month okay um it's probably not
fourth year that we actually like
started like paying people sensible
money like 50 Grand 40 Grand yeah 60
Grand and all that stuff yeah I guess
like when you switch from thinking per
month to per year that's yeah exactly
exactly right so I'm like two round a
month oh [ __ ] around I'm like 60 Grand
yeah exactly yeah okay so what did the
case studies look like like what's an
example of a case study from a case
study so a good case study is of like uh
I don't know
um new look right New Look came to us to
reach young people what we did was we
got like YouTube influencers to do a
fashion haul and then link directly the
case study got you know 10 000 clicks
and 5 000 purchases like very
straightforward okay now it's got more
sophisticated at the beginning I think
we were very juvenile you know what at
the beginning we were driven by fear a
lot yeah I actually say this to Ambrose
a lot which is like
so at the beginning I was driven by two
things number one was a bit of fear
because I was like
and is the fear which meant we didn't
charge people a lot of money okay Fiera
then oh I'm not sure snake oil kind of
stuff for our first ever campaign was
with go ape and I charged them 300 pound
and they said yeah and I caught up
Ambrose I was like yo we did it 300
pounds and it's so crazy because like
four years before I had just sold my
company for way more than that but it
was a new idea A New Concept a new
service and like someone that paid us
300 pounds oh my God I can't believe
this and then um
yeah it was a bit of fear
um and then probably like you know you
know third year when we were more
comfortable with the fact that we can
actually you know charge higher prices
that's when we did that were you worried
at all about how you would actually
drive results because the thing with
marketing is that it's it's a bit of a
rolling of the dice right or am I what
am I just saying about it yeah but I was
concerned but I think that's where
Ambrose uh became really like really
came into his own he was um he was my
CEO loves a spreadsheet loves all that
stuff right and so he was really you
know being like right you know if we get
these amount of views that should lead
to this blah blah blah blah um so he was
he was pretty good in that
um and you were confident enough that
hey if we hire the right influencers we
can get x amount of views and
theoretically that should lead to an 80
conversion yeah yeah
um I think when we started it you know
even in our second third year
we're just like
it's okay if this campaign flops because
like there'll be another campaign you
know I think
I had a lot of belief in ourselves that
we do that and also I think we were also
optimizing for Speed like
we had a venture capitalist come to us
and say right why not just raise like
five six million let's take this you
know
how does this become like a hundred
million dollar business and all that
stuff
and I remember saying to him it's just
not gonna be that and he was like wait
what and I was like yeah this business
is not going to be a 100 million dollar
business like
it's going to make tens of millions
guaranteed
and he was like okay and then he put in
money by himself not through his fund
and when we then sold the company I then
uh texted him and I said do you remember
the first time that we met
you were like how is this going to be a
billion dollar outcome and I said it's
not going to be a billion dollar outcome
but like this is exactly how much is
gonna sell for
um
and it was exactly the amount how how
did you how did you know like at that
level when we're talking tens of
millions versus hundreds of millions
versus billion like
all three sets of those numbers are
equally unfathomable so what's going
through your mind to be able to actually
yeah run that calculation so what's
going through my mind is two things the
first thing is I had a very good idea of
how businesses like us are valued
um through a combination of revenue and
profit and growth rate and all that
stuff so even now I invest and I advise
in a bunch of like you know B2B
businesses and I'm like if you reach
this number and if you do this you can
sell for within this range what sort of
multiples are there on these sorts of
businesses uh if you have Tech and
revenue
um generally you can look at like two to
four times okay Revenue okay typically
most of the businesses though are a
multiple of profits but that's if you
don't have Tech and we had a good amount
of tech
um which again was intentional right
because we wanted to build a business
that was like that had a lot of value
beyond the people yeah and that was very
intentional so many people this is like
a complete side note um so many people
see like TechCrunch right they read
TechCrunch and
and I'd ask them oh so where do you
think their business would go billion
dollars it's like based on what it's
like well you know billion dollars it's
like based on what because fundamentally
when a company buys you they buy new
because they think that like by you
joining them they can make more money
right because if I can buy for
five pounds and I can make ten pounds
I'm just gonna make that trade every
single day yeah right and so um
and so for me
um I kind of understood that right like
someone buy us at this level because
baseball growth rate Revenue clients Etc
like they could make
x amount so therefore just make that
trade interesting so in pure Tech often
the multiples are sort of 10 but 10
times 10 times revenue or something
absurd like that but that's pure Tech
where you've got recurring revenue and
they have a like they're like all right
cool I know that this will work for the
next accident videos and run that
calculation but I guess in this context
if let's say we pluck a number of thin
air like I don't know 30 million just to
make the numbers and assume a 3X
multiple of Revenue that means for
someone to buy you for 30 million you
would need to be getting 10 million top
line revenue
and in order to get that multiple of
Revenue you need some kind of tech
platform which means you need a way to
measure engagement or measure or
something or something yeah or like some
kind of Ip that yeah they want to buy
from you or like repeat clients client
retention needs to be high all that
stuff there
um so you need all that type of stuff
and then you're thinking okay is it
doable to get to let's say 10 million
top line revenue and you're thinking
well actually yes because all we need is
10 campaigns of a million half million
exactly and then like these are the
people that you need to have
yeah
it's quite surgical yeah it's quite
surgical the approach
um one of the questions I ask one of the
questions I get asked a lot is like how
do you feel you know now that you've
sold your company Etc and my thing is
always like
it was exactly how I designed it yeah it
was like exactly how I designed it
because I was like okay it's gonna
happen it's gonna happen and it's and
it's also very important that when
people talk about Acquisitions they
don't think about it as kind of like
let's say if you're like
getting one over the company right some
people go like oh I saw my company and
it's like well you created something of
value you realize to give you a value to
like someone else and so therefore you
then sold it and you saw something of
value it's not like you sold a dud or or
um or something or something like that
and the other thing that really helps
with like business valuations is if you
can be seen as kind of a competitive
threat to someone oh what do you mean so
for example we had four offers right
four people want to buy fan lights
and at least one of them we had taken
a couple of clients from them
and so we were a competitive threat to
them yeah right it was like more
worthwhile yeah exactly right exactly
hey look at you know figma sell into
Adobe it's a perfect example of like
competitive threat it's like they are
taking our customers if we spend 20
billion we can make whatever 60 billion
by not only their customers coming into
the Adobe fold but then using our other
products yeah and like linking them all
up so Photoshop design can go into figma
rather than XD which no one uses exactly
and all that exactly competitive tension
drives a lot more deals than people
think it does huge is there anything
like it's if someone's listening to this
and they're like I want to be an a
player it's skills you would encourage
them to cultivate in order to be one of
those a players one of the things that I
really enjoyed working with you know
High performing people is that they just
generally have a bias towards action
like
they know that they can try several
things and maybe quite a few of them
would flop but they're not concerned
with that they're just concerned with
taking as many shots on go and I think
especially when you were young and
beginning in your journey you over
glamorize strategy all right yeah you
like over glamorize like you know let's
do all this stuff here
and you
and you underestimate the value of just
taking shots on goal
um because you have to take as many
shots in order for like one of them to
go in so you might as well have like a
bias toward action and I find that is
missing from a lot of people
um especially people
in their 20s 100 why why do you think
that is
I think it's because the things that
they're comparing themselves to are like
people who do the thinking so they think
so a very good example is someone might
see me and go oh like he's a CEO and he
does thinking around The Who and the
people Etc but at the beginning I was
building the funnels I was building the
proposals I was just like doing doing
stuff I was like sending in the emails I
was I was like sending all that stuff
and so you can't compare me to like
me five six years down the line because
I've had to do all the other stuff so
you have to start from here in order to
get up there yeah and I think that in a
way that's one of the issues with books
about business and books about success
in that they tend to be high level yeah
they tend to be aimed at Executives yeah
and they tend to be our people are the
most important thing and like your
strategy is really important because of
one percent deviation it's like who
cares okay that's completely completely
relevant for someone sitting on the
ground
I've never read this book by Simon sinek
yeah I've never read it I know everyone
talks about it but I've never read it
because I've you know I think at no
point in my life had I got to the point
where I thought right let me think about
the like the why and the purpose of like
galvanizing the team and the vision and
all that stuff I've just been like act
just
learn do learn do right
um I may do that for the next company
right but like
I think that I'd always had a bias
toward action and the best people have a
biased towards action
yeah that's a good a good quote from the
book attraction which is that um Vision
Without execution is hallucination and
so like start of executing make the
money and then you can worry about
division and the strategy and the
mission statement and the values and all
that [ __ ] like further down the line but
why if that's like trying to spend ages
on a business card when you haven't made
any money like exactly don't worry about
it exactly
um what's your how do you feel about
personal brands
hello favorite personal brand so I think
a personal brand is a very
so
in business you want to make sure that
you have as many competitive advantages
as possible Right some of them is you
raise a bunch of money that your
competitors can't some of them is that
you enter into a niche that your
competitors can't right one of the uh
competitive advantages is a personal
brand right because fundamentally it is
almost like another tool you can use to
attract customers and employees that
your competitors can't right
um you know when we began the sale of
the business we appointed a m a bank to
like run the whole process and all that
stuff because basically there's a whole
thing which I can explain basically when
you do Acquisitions less than roughly 10
million people often say like you can
kind of
you can use like a broker or you can DIY
right
um anything above 10 15 million you
generally advise to use a bank right
what does the bank do in this case so
what does an M A Bank do so
when we thought right this is the right
time so we'd been approached a lot by
like private Equity companies so to
explain what a private Equity companies
are they just people with a lot of money
who want to buy your company because
they think they can like sell it later
on for a bigger number so we've been
approached by uh PE companies private
equity and we basically decided that oh
okay this is the time for a deal we
didn't go down the private Equity route
we actually thought it makes sense for
us to go down the Strategic routes
strategic acquisition from a competitor
or something no you've never had a
company that wants to absorb the
influence marketing thing into there
yeah exactly okay fine exactly we
decided that rather than a private
Equity buyer
um
and so when we decided that we then went
to connect with an m a bank and what an
M A Bank does is basically they're
basically like the deal maker so their
whole thing is they help companies to
buy companies and also to sell companies
what they do is they'll come up with
like a really kind of they'll come up
with a nice presentation for you
tense lies just like talking about the
company
then they send it out to some small
group of people
um if they say oh this is interesting
I'd like to chat then they introduce you
to them and they help you to then kind
of have that intro call and everything
else
hang on so you're saying if I build a
company and I want to sell it yeah I can
get someone else to sell it for me I
don't have to go I don't have to wait
for emails to come in yeah [ __ ] four
percentage of the revenue yeah
um okay cool Sorry exactly so they make
a presentation they send it out to some
people and they're like we've got this
company on sale for 15 million so that's
the thing they don't tell the price ah
okay they're wearing something on sale
and here are their stats yeah and like
generally and generally it is um
no discrete it is
they don't say the name of the company
oh okay yeah like so it's more like in
the influencer marketing space the
company in the influencer market which
does blah blah blah this is cool Etc all
right
and then when they say right this is
interesting then you have some people
who say right this interesting this fits
inside of our thesis of you know the
future or some other
and then you meet those companies and
you then go on you know some meetings
with them a bit of a journey with them
Etc you know meeting them and not only
for them to see if you're a good fit but
for you to also see they're a good fit
fun fact like we actually were
approached by this other company and I
went into the office and the office was
just so hot
it was just like just hot and it was
because they were using like old
computers and the fans were wearing and
everything and I just left and I
remember sending a uh voice note to
Ambrose I was like even if they paid 100
million nobody's ever going there right
and this is actually quite interesting
because it shows the transformation from
Karen about
um like money to actually like caring
about like a good significant exit
anyway so these Bankers then they'll
like chat with you and then you chat
with the companies and then once that's
done
uh a set of companies put together
something called a letter of intent and
Loi and that basically says we intend to
buy you for this amount and then what
then happens is
um you then decide which company you
want to go forward with okay and that
then opens roughly like 10 weeks or so
in which of um of exclusivity so that
basically means that in those 10 weeks
you're gonna open up basically every
part of your business your finances your
legal and then at the end of that they
say right we are satisfied with this
because remember in the ideal process in
that 10 weeks they can say actually you
said your company was doing X but it's
actually not so either the deals off or
that price that we said we're actually
gonna reduce it right and presumably
they're doing whatever they can in that
10 weeks to really reduce that number no
no they actually want the price to go
ahead
some bad buyers
um they do this and it's called renegan
so basically they're like renege on the
deal and basically they'll be like oh we
said 50 actually you said this and now
we're doing at 40. in our deal it went
fine the price that they said was the
price that they said done
um and then at the end during those 10
weeks yeah what's going through your
mind how are you feeling what's going on
so here's a here's the interesting thing
um
my co-founder Ambrose was the one who
really did a lot of stuff there right
like the the like
like us
and the bank basically did all the stuff
around like the data room and Excel
sheets Etc so I didn't feel that much
stress
um I think I also knew that a deal would
go ahead and so like because
I knew and I like told myself like there
is no conceivable World in which a deal
does not go ahead I was just like oh
cool right and I had Faith as well in
the company that like they would
actually do what they say this is
actually a very good
um
this is where an M A Bank really comes
in because they are like your
intermediary because may you can get
emotional when these deals right because
like basically someone in two three four
months is about to give you
life-changing money at any point if
they're like this doesn't work okay
that's fine just take it okay let's just
take right the biggest thing people do
when they're trying to sell the
companies if they don't use a bank or
like an intermediary is they concede too
much because they just want the deal
done so like they can get the money so
an m a bank is exceptional there to
basically be like you know actually you
know I don't think that's the case I
don't think that's the thing right to be
almost your grown up whilst you're
acting like a petulant little child
um they're the people there for you
um yeah and so at the end of 10 weeks
they then do a uh share purchase
agreement and then you sign the share
purchase agreement and that's it how did
how do did you feel when you saw the
numbers on the letters of intent that
you got fine yeah I think I think it
didn't feel real yeah
the bit that felt real there were two
moments that felt real yeah the first
moment was when we signed the share
purchase agreement because you know they
tell you the letter of intent and you
know the price the share purchase
agreement I remember this and I actually
have a uh video of this um
uh uh on my phone
like everyone else is signing we have
invested sign in we have builted us like
everyone is you know signing that stuff
and then the final thing is we then have
to sign so me CEO CTO we have to you
know sign so
Mitchell signs cool and I'm recording
all of this on Zoom right so and bear in
mind it's like again like Friday 1am
because all our lawyers and their
lawyers have just been working on it
working on it which I've often found so
ridiculous in the fact that like you
have all this time to work on a deal and
you still push it to the end it's like
what's going on anyway uh and then
Ambrose signs and I remember recording
this and I say guys like you know
like
six years ago we met and we said this is
going to be a thing I know there's been
a lot of challenges and everything else
I'm so proud of everything that we've
ever done and I'm so happy and then I
signed and then on Gmail we just got
this DocuSign thing which says like
everyone has signed and I find it crazy
to think that you just get a Gmail email
which symbolizes like
a life-changing thing and you just go
like all done it's like
and that to me was like very I was like
Wow and the crazy thing about that is I
done went to bed and the next day I just
went to gym and it was just like I've
just transformed my life and everything
else is normal and then the final one
the second one is when the money
actually dropped that was that was when
I was like wow like we actually did this
because beforehand it's all like
on the screen and you're like okay this
crap and they go online has actually
happened
um
there's a crazy story about that
actually and I'll just take quickly was
Mitch and Ambrose are on um
Lloyd's account and I was on a Santander
account and uh lawyers had sent over the
money and they'd got theirs first so we
were like walking around saying what's
going on the money hasn't dropped and
then ambrosis Ambrose refreshing the
screen and it's like when he said oh my
God oh my God and then I refresh my
screen and it's like nothing
it's like what's going on and I'm
freaking out because I'm like wait did I
give them the right sort code account
number I'm thinking there's someone else
here who's got millions in their account
what's going on
um and I'm oh my god
um and then and then I'm like hey blah
blah and then I refresh again and then
comes to you and I remember just like
screaming
um because office wasn't founded I was
screaming just like scream I was like oh
my God oh my God and the craziest thing
I did was later that day I went to my
dad's grave and I was just like
I was just crying I was just crying I
was crying I was crying and I was like I
was like like we [ __ ] did it like we
did it like we did it all right I'll
just tears of like falling down my eyes
because I just felt like from when he
said he was proud of me to now it was
like boom you did it man
um so those were the two moments where I
was like oh like this is real like this
is very real
um no but yeah crazy so what what's next
you've reached the summit of first
Mountain how does it feel
yeah I think I think one of the things
that I wish I had when I was younger was
I wish there was someone like me who
could share a lot of the ways and the
Frameworks that they used to get to
where they were I think I'm kind of
thinking about how I can do that you
know there's the other stuff there like
you know property and you know property
and investing and money management and
all that stuff
but I think right now I'm just I'm
trying to focus on um interesting things
with interesting people
[Music]
um
that's it really so you presumably have
more time on your hands now that you're
um kind of a vagabond and roaming around
the streets just chilling I'm going to
the gym what how are you spending your
time these days yes so I think I mean
you know when we saw the company a big
part of it was like we did believe that
like for this influencer division or
this influencer thing to grow like brain
Labs the company borders where the best
you know partner to take forward so I'm
supporting them with that
um which is all around you know like
just hiring great people going global
all that stuff I mean fun fact like when
we sold the company 40 of our Revenue
was from the us but we didn't have a
single person there which is just like
outrageous
um you know helping with that
um but now we you know now I have a bit
more time right which therefore means
that I'm doing interesting things like
so
with my experience and you know having
like builds and skilled and sold a
company I'm doing quite a lot of stuff
around investing I'm actually doing
quite a lot of like PE stuff so actually
like
um helping to buy companies
um and then kind of shaping them up to
exit so you have done that in like the
e-commerce space done then quite a few
things
um why like why are they trying to make
more money or what's what's the what's
the aim at this point so I think it's a
fun game of like
if you think about it right if you look
at a business and you go I think here
are five ways we can optimize you like
relatively easily
um
and you can do that and increase the
value of the business that's a fun game
yeah right that's like buying a house
and fixing it up because you're like
fixing things up and just yeah yeah it's
kind of fun yeah exactly right there's
people who love that game and uh for me
that's an interesting game so like
buying and selling companies investing
um although increasingly I'm starting to
look at an invest in like just gambling
I'm just like bro I'm just like cool
here is 50k I don't know what's gonna
happen but you know Vibes
um like Angel Investing yeah yeah
um but I'm trying to do I'm trying to do
less of that more where I can influence
the outcome okay so like rather than you
know
25k checks actually being like all right
here's 100 Grand but I'll be like
like on the board of the company and we
will help it to steer that way rather
than just like oh you know here's some
cash you know uh because I still want to
ensure that fan bites keeps growing to
the part that is
um yeah so that's it
how have your attitudes towards money
changed from kind of age 14 thinking a
Mercedes-Benz cost 500 quid and making
you know a few quit an hour to you know
having a life-changing exit like what
was the that Journey
so I think at the beginning I think
there's also the case with quite a lot
of people I think at the beginning I had
quite a scarcity mindset towards money
um I very much was like oh I've got this
I have to make sure that you know it
doesn't go
and I think over time because I've
proved to myself that I've become the
type of person who can create value and
make money I now approach it with a lot
more
abundance a lot more like oh yeah cool
that's fine okay this happens this
happens and I'm very aware that it's
very I guess like fortunate uh position
to be in but like
think that was a big change was just
going from scarcity to abundance and
you know every time you'd hear people
say like you know money doesn't make you
happy Etc it's like like yes that's true
but I'm also significantly happier right
and like
um
um I'm also significantly happier than I
was
like when I didn't have it so
um those will probably be the two main
ones but I think definitely going from
scarcity to abundance and actually think
a mental trick I should have done when I
was younger was I think I should have
tried to like program my mind to think
more in abundance rather than waiting
for the money to come to then think in
abundance
that was a mistake if I had treated
money as more like uh oh you know like
you know it Ebbs and it flows it goes
from here it goes from here I just need
to become the type of person who can do
it blah blah like I would not have held
on to things for too long and I also
would not have made certain decisions
which were based out of like I don't
want to lose
um rather than now I'm just like oh cool
whatever so let's say someone's
listening to this and they currently
have a scarcity mindset towards money
and they're thinking I'll tell him easy
for you to say you've got I know
um that was me yeah uh what would be the
instructions that the the code for the
firmware update to get that mental model
of money the one that's more abundant
rather than scarce assuming you don't
have several zeros after your bank
account balance
money comes as a result of the person
that you are and the person that you are
is by and large a consequence of like
the skills and the habits that you have
so rather than optimizing for the money
like focus on like skill acquisition
right for example with me I really
in our first two years and really in our
first yeah three four years
all the brands that came to us were due
to inbound like they'd come to us rather
than us going directly to them and it's
because we became very good at like
building marketing funnels and all that
stuff that brought in Brands and I
learned those funnels from like again
Russell Brunson and all these guys so
I'd build all these funnels that'll
become the like foundation of the
business and that will bring people in
so I thought more about like the skills
I was cultivating and as a consequence
of those skills I was then able to
create something of value and then those
things are valued and made me money so
to that you know young person thinking
that I'd say yes a I know it's
incredibly
um challenging to think like that when
you don't have money but it's very
important to focus on like the skills
and actually cultivating skills which
can then lead to money which is things
like you know marketing and sales and uh
copywriting things like that like you
want to focus on just like being off
used to the economy because if you're of
like General use in some way people will
pay you for that and like that's the way
that you create value it's almost like
leveling up in a video game yeah if you
want if you want to get the gear to take
down that end game Boss you need to
level up yeah you need to do all this
stuff level up yeah train up to these
different trade skills that's why I was
talking about cheat codes yeah actually
with the book
um with a book one of the titles one of
the suggested titles was basically
around cheat codes it was like it was
something like
it's basically like how to discover the
cheat codes to winning in business and
life or something Dan actually told me
not to go with that title because he
said that you don't want to be linked
with the word cheating so I was like
okay cool but but um but I do see it as
a game
um I've just you know figuring out the
inputs okay that worked that didn't work
done yeah yeah this is something I was
talking about with um Alexi as well in
in the podcast
um this idea that
like I know so many people who who like
come to me and they're like hey Ali you
know you know about this investing stuff
you know I'm I'm currently making I
don't know 50k in my job and I'm saving
10 and I want to put it in the you know
index funds or like individual stocks
and I'm like
I mean the right answer is index funds
but actually the that's the wrong answer
because what you're gonna earn three
four six percent and when you're 55 then
then you'll be good like instead if you
can find a way to invest those things in
your own education yeah so that you
become the sort of person who then can
command a premium yeah and can just make
money yeah individual that's way more
Roi positive yeah and the way homozy
describes it is that it's investing in
the SNP versus the S and me
oh that's good there you go yeah I mean
you know like people talk about
companion interest but you almost want
to you know compound yourself yeah like
that's way better if you if you
the Returns on compounding yourself are
way more than any stock right yeah than
you could ever
more than any crypto yeah and I guess
almost the there's like a tier list of
this almost where it's like most like
the the top returns when companies
yourself the second top returns are are
in investing in your own business yeah
and then worst case scenario S P 500
okay once you once you have literally no
other options and the money's just
sitting there burning a hole in your
account yeah okay fine yeah let's try
and go for seven percent to be inflation
but like there are so many options
beyond that point yeah but I think
people default to oh I should invest
because especially I think in
traditional Fields like I know so many
doctors who feel like they don't have
any skills outside of medicine how do
you make money investing is the only
option yeah um rather than I actually
could start a business yeah I could
learn how to do that yeah you want to
almost like see yourself
one of the things that I say to friends
is that you want to see yourself as like
a SIMS character oh okay tell me more
that you're almost just like there and
you're playing Sims and like you're the
character and then it's like okay go
left all right cool it's like go to gym
I go to the gym I do this all right like
do not eat now okay I shall not eat now
right like I type on laptop right cool
so
when you have a SIMS character and you
just like tell it to do stuff it just it
just like goes and does stuff and I've
often tried to see my life as a bit of a
SIMS character like I am now in good
shape and beforehand I was not in good
shape and I was like okay what are the
two things that I need to do to be in
good shape well eat less move more done
right so I eat less so sometimes I'll be
hungry and I'm like well I'm not gonna
eat now okay I don't eat right
um I'm not gonna you know move more gym
cool I now go to the gym so I think I
treat myself almost like a SIMS
character because I'm just like whoa
um if a SIMS character can do it then
why can't you you know
um that's kind of the mentality that I
have towards us life in general of it do
you slash did you ever struggle with
procrastination
oh yeah
but I told myself that everyone else did
so it's fine so I basically have to like
procrastinate less
so rather than trying to stop
procrastinating I just said I will
procrastinate less and that helped me my
formal procrastination which is probably
similar to you is like
it's not that you waste time doing
meaningless stuff is that you waste time
doing the less important thing right
yeah so you're like I know I need to do
this but I'm going to read this book
instead right all right
um so I just became aware of that and I
just said like don't fight
procrastination just try and
procrastinate less yeah which is very
different from like I am not going to
procrastinate because I don't think
anyway in my case I don't think it was
possible for me not to procrastinate
yeah I think it was just procrastinating
less yeah yeah I think I think for me as
well it was
like so many of the skills I've done
over time have been because I was
procrastinating from doing something
else something else I should have done
like you know I can't be able to do my
homework right now let me just Tinker
with some like web designers oh hello
it's a nice gradient yeah exactly over
time you just develop these skills
through procrastination yeah
um the only procrastination that doesn't
develop skills I think is when I find
myself just like randomly scrolling
Instagram or Twitter yeah why am I doing
this like yeah yeah um and in a way
huh I've just thought of this the fact
that we have a phone and our phone is
our go to device of procrastination yeah
it's a lot harder to do
interesting things on a phone than it is
on a desktop computer yeah back in the
day when you and I are sitting at home
on our laptops or a computer or
something and you want to procrastinate
oh let's go on a subreddit for marketing
let's go on web design subreddit yeah
I'm not going to go on a subreddit on my
phone I'm gonna go Twitter on my phone
because it's so easy yeah so in a way
like procrastinating got a computer is
just inherently worth more overall to
compounding yourself and procrastinating
on a phone yeah a little hot take there
um what do you do when you know you
should do something or you have to do
something and you can't be asked to do
it like what what's what's the process
do you do you think I'm a SIMS character
I will just do the thing like how how
does it work
so I think I just do the thing um
regardless of how you feel about it yeah
I I don't feel like going to the gym
right now you know last night I was like
oh it's midnight and there's McDonald's
drive through there you know what let's
let's go in I don't know I mean so
there's a very good book I read called
be your future self now and this reading
guide is written by a guy called uh Ben
Hardy oh I know him yeah he's great and
I really like it because I always ask
myself like what would my future self do
yeah and so you know going to the gym my
house like there's a gym box pretty
close by I also have like a gym set up
at home so I'm just like cool I'm just
gonna go to the gym
um
yeah how do you balance what would my
future self do with I want to have fun
in the Here and Now it depends on your
definition of fun
like whoa
so I'm thinking like I know my future
self means I would probably not want me
to eat the McDonald's meal deal at
midnight but I really want to eat the
McDonald's meal deal and there's oh
there's there's always I feel like
there's always a tension between the
thing that drives long-term results and
the thing that feels good right now
often I can feel you know like last
night I canceled my session with my
personal trainer because my girlfriend
was unwell and I felt yes I don't have
to do my personal trainer session and
it's like
that's funny it feels good to not do a
thing that you know you should do
because you know it's gonna be painful
because everything that's worth doing
tends to feel a little bit just
uncomfortable
I think that for me
I just changed my definition of fun um
that I do find it fun to do the like
unpleasant things
so yeah nice I think that I had to
almost rewire my mind to uh to do that
I'm trying to think because one of the
questions I get asked a lot by friends
is like oh you know why don't you chill
out and want to do that and I'm like
because I'd find that more yeah so the
thing that I find fun is like
tinkering with projects and Tinker with
ideas and like you know talking to
people and them saying you know you've
changed this you've changed that all
right that well like that's fun to me so
I think that I just rewired my
definition of fun
yeah
it's it's interesting to say that so
I've been reading some studies that
basically talk about exactly this um in
research for the book and stuff around
how
you can actually train your mind to feel
a dopamine hit from
discomfort or from lifting the bench
press thing that's like harder rather
than the reward at the end because if
you train yourself to feel that dopamine
from the donut you have at the end or
the McDonald's drive-through like I do
that's the sort of uh compounding in the
wrong direction yeah yeah whereas if you
can genuinely train your brain to
genuinely feel enjoyment and fun and
energy from doing the thing that looks
like work yeah you're just like winning
because it feels it feels like play yeah
there's a there's a book I'm reading
actually uh let me get the name it is
called designing the mind the principles
of psychotecture sick I'm just buying
that on and it is one of you know my
favorite book is a book called psycho
cybernetics oh it's sick I read that
when I was like in year nine or
something it's [ __ ] game changing
yeah yeah yeah like the whole idea of
like neuroplasticity and all that stuff
you say oh my God yeah and this book
about design the mind it it's almost the
modern version of that which is like you
can rewire your mind to assign different
meanings to different things you can
literally like Invent Yourself and so I
think that approach is what I took to
just uh
like so you know in your example I take
a lot of uh pleasure from like being at
the gym and doing like a
PR on bench press because I'm like like
that's just more pleasurable right I
take more pleasure from being like oh
I've actually gone on like an 18 hour
fast
because I'm just like yeah that's just
more pleasurable
um
yeah that book you know psycho
cybernetics there's another one which I
just forgot but like sexual analytics
and designed mind I just found them to
be like why is this not taught in GCSE
like people should understand the idea
of neuroplasticity and being able to
like change your mind and change your
brain like people just know this but um
has there been any other books that have
had a big impact on you
so good they can't ignore you oh yeah by
car Newport that was a great one
um I think all the books by Russell
Brunson I've never read any of this
stuff I think that like my I started
working with a CEO coach like three days
ago okay and he was telling me you need
to read Russell brunson's Trilogy of
books just because I I know so little
about marketing and he was like I guess
we'll just level you up and see you yeah
so yeah that yeah so you should do that
I will do that
um so good they can't ignore you psycho
cybernetics uh what did you take away
from so good they can't ignore you well
just the value of skills that was why I
said earlier they're like don't focus on
the money just like focus on building
rare and valuable skills and if you do
that you will always be in demand so
like right now you could put me anywhere
in the world and
I'll be fine because I get sales I get
marketing I get public speaking I get
people I get communication done let's
say you were designed you were
controlling the same as character
um like right now it's late 2022 someone
let's say they've got normal job and
they're like I want to build a business
on the side but they don't have any
skills outside of I don't know being a
doctor or something because I have a
very specific skill set but like doesn't
necessarily apply to business what would
be your kind of uh syllabus for your
little similar character to go around to
build up the business skills too yeah so
the first thing I would do
is I will try and focus I will ask
myself what errors
can I help
other people make more money
so
for example like if you really think
about what fan bites was it was an
engine for a brand to be able to spend
say 50 Grand and make
like 70 grand yeah right we spend 50
Grand on a campaign it made us 70 grand
in profit or whatever
so therefore I'll just keep making that
trade over and over so
um
when I say to that person is like like
focus on a space focus on an area focus
on an industry where you can help people
make more money and the people could be
consumers but it could also be
businesses I generally prefer businesses
right businesses have money businesses
want to spend money consumers don't
exactly and there's also a clear sign of
Roi and it's like if I do this I can
help them because fundamentally if you
can help someone I guess like
if by someone spending a pound with you
they can make three pounds and in return
you say I want to pound fifty
you've built a Perpetual machine right
because then I'm just gonna keep um
spending spending so I say firstly is
look for where
um you can help people make more money
relatively
um quickly so by quickly I mean just you
know like like they can spend and they
can get the outcome quite quickly
I would focus on like a type of skill so
I personally think if you were young or
anything one of the best skills you can
have is copywriting like being able to
write to persuade people to me it's like
magic I can just type on Keys put some
words together configure them in a
certain way and that can persuade
someone to then like take out their card
and pay me
um those would be the skills that I'd
focus on and then
once you've got that understanding of
right I've figured out the market I
figured out
a model in which I can help them make
more money than really all you have to
do is just like persuade people
to um to get you to
um to work with them and the way they do
that is that you work for free at the
beginning have two three four case
studies and then you just keep doing it
yeah
most of business I've come to realize is
like relatively straightforward it's
just the mind which just like makes you
think it's uh confusing but like what we
did at Fan bites
is not like
it's not like d-tech right it's not
science it's not it's not it's not
anything that's like intellectually like
challenging it's just like emotionally
difficult because when we email Brands
and they wouldn't respond or we'd put a
proposal together and the brand would go
with a competitor or they'll do this and
they'll do that like that's the hard bit
but the actual doing of business is like
relatively straightforward yeah yeah I
find that one of the things that also
holds people back is just not
appreciating the meaning of money
and like in in the sense of you know I
got an email the other day some company
offering me 20K to give a talk for
freaking half an hour yeah that's like
half of a year are working full-time as
a junior doctor like it's just freaking
insane
and to this company it's just a bit
pocket change and just the fact that
that
massive disparity in how companies and
individuals value money just freaking
game changing yeah and we found that you
know there have been people who've
worked for me as employees who've then
done gone on to do freelancy type stuff
yeah and they're just sort of almost
like hey I just doubled my price and
they didn't bet an island yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna quadruple it next time and you
get that thing where they almost can't
believe it it feels like it's a cheat
code yeah especially when you're selling
a server to a business who wants to make
money with specific outcome you're just
like bloody hell I used to think making
12 pounds an hour was good
no I've just sent an email and I've gone
from 2K month to 5K a month and they
didn't even download it what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah is when you move towards like
you know pricing based of value right
um
there's a very good talk I remember
reading sort of reading watching and it
changed my life I think it was by Jim
Rohn
or Brian Tracy basically they said you
get value for what you provide to the
marketplace and I remember that just
like like changing my whole I was just
like oh like that's how people get paid
for stuff because they create something
of value and then like people pay for
that value it's like oh that makes the
most yeah it sounds so simple but
actually
there's it's such a I think it's
it's how basically like all of
philosophy you can like you can condense
Plato's Republic to just a single phrase
of like be nice to people or something
like that but actually there's so much
experience that it gets summarized into
that one idea and the idea of provide
something of value
people would pay for it
there's actually there's a lot of
experience behind something that's
tweetable like that exactly and I guess
the mistake that some some people make
is they read all that and they're like
not along yeah never create anything
that's a value to the marketplace yeah I
think I think I may create
a t-shirt would just says act on it like
just do shits right
um because you have to do something to
get some outcome yeah if you don't do
anything they're not going to get it
I'll come you know yeah
I think in the world of business like um
that's the thing I've been thinking
recently like I think a lot of people
conflate value value to the marketplace
with my value as an individual yes
yes oh my God yes
yes 100
what do you mean tell me more
um what did that spot for you like I
talk to people
and
they have to do a specific thing right
it's like all right
you have a I don't know a nail salon or
something right you therefore need to
learn how to advertise on Instagram
because that's going to attract people
to you oh I don't know how to
I'm not a social media person
what do you think that we just
out of our mom's bellies and just know
how to use tick tock like come on you
know like it's an action that you have
to learn it's an action that you have to
do to provide value and that's one thing
which really gets to me like I'm not
this type of person and the truth is
like you're not any type of person right
like who you currently are is just a
bunch of like actions and beliefs that
have happened in the past that make you
now so therefore you can be any type of
person and so people go around like you
know value to the marketplace and
they're like oh I know I should be good
at sales and marketing but the value to
myself is like I'm not a sales and
marketing person I've never learned it
therefore I can't learn it it's like
what what's happening to you right like
you're not a stickman who just like
stays there and just come on you know
um that really really infuriates me when
people just don't go like come on like
you can be more and also you should
choose to be more because you're not a
static thing right
um so yeah I can be agree and it just
infuriates me so much when people just
have that kind of like well here I am
and the phrase that massively infuriates
me is um
um uh well that's just the way I am what
like the way you are is due to a bunch
of past experiences you've had so the
future you if you think about the future
you being a combination of the past
experiences that you have then it's
every experience that you've had from
now to the Future you will be the past
so you might as well do it you know
anyway run over
do you get any other questions that make
your that grind your gears
I mean that's the first one
um uh I love passion yeah I know and the
reason why it annoys me is because I see
people who are way more intelligent than
me like
mess up because they are not able to
confront this question of like you can
be more like
I'm thinking about two or three people
now where I'm like you could be whatever
you want to be but you think you're just
a fixed type of person and so because of
that you're not going to be that person
and every time I see that person a part
of me just goes man I
I don't know how to get this into you
but man you could be brilliant
um
that's the main question yeah that's the
main one right
okay thank you thank you so much we're
probably a good place to end this um
yeah it was fun all right so that's it
for this week's episode of Deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye